how do you improve or make a story
better well there's a lot of ways that
you can make a story better the the most
effective way I've found is to make it
shorter the thing I've learned one of
the big things I learned at CSUN was
that there can't be any superfluous
moment in a screenplay because the
attention of an audience is so short you
need to constantly be showing them what
the next step is what the next question
is what the next mystery is there's not
a lot of time for you to go on tangents
that are not directly related to the
story of the film now I talked about
before being able to go on tangents
through the eight sequence method in
that case even the tangents are directly
related to the main storyline in some
way so like in the case of misery when
we follow the sheriff as he tries to
figure out what's going on with this
missing guy and he ends up going to the
house we're not following the main
character but we're following a
character that's going to come in
contact with that character so it's it's
vital that every single scene be
directly related to the narrative spine
of it you know finding a way to make all
your characters unique is something
that's always good one of the common
tricks that I actually use and that's
actually very effective is if you write
a scene and if you cover the names of
all the characters if you read the scene
just the dialogue and you don't
immediately know who the characters are
based on what they're saying you need to
go back and figure out a way to write it
so that it's specific to that character
and that's a very effective way to kind
of improve the uniqueness of the
characters in your story you know
whether it's by changing the cadence of
how they talk whether it's changing the
point of view of what they're saying you
know figuring out why they're saying it
it helps to deepen who those characters
are those are those are some ways I
think that can help talk about sort of
you know like cutting the fat to speed
it up but one thing I love
and I feel like we've gotten too fast
paced with some of the movies and maybe
that's just because I'm in a different
generation you know but it seems like
it's a real art form to actually have it
be fast enough for television let's say
like sharp objects it felt like a slower
paced thing but I get it if you broke
down
just all the different scenes and and
sequences and and you know shots and
stuff it was probably very quick but
there was a slow feel to it and the last
black man in San Francisco it was a
slower feel to it but I mean I'm sure if
he boiled it down it was actually quite
fast paced but I think that's a real art
oh absolutely and part of that ties into
the way that you film the story you know
you think of like big little lies
there's that to me didn't feel all that
fast paced because you have a lot of
scenes you know with like Nicole Kidman
for example in therapy those scenes even
though they're vital to the story they
don't lend themselves to snap bang fast
action storytelling so the the type of
story that you're telling can help to
affect the pacing of it even if it is
properly structured in the script the
way that you film it can have a big
effect on that that's true because I'm
thinking of like the different women in
there and they're sort of they're
emotionals wine-drinking scene where the
beautiful ocean like a lot of those
season at least create scenes I'm like
wow I wish I could live there but you
know so and then they're having this
sort of meltdown and a husband is like
honey it's okay you know and it was very
it felt very slow moving but I get it it
probably was was just a quick moment
yeah yeah and it's all the style the
filmmaker - you know I won one film I
think of a lot in terms of that is the
Big Lebowski so that film if you read
the script the script moves pretty quick
but if you watch the film the film takes
place in a lot of single shots and it
moves very the camera moves very slowly
as the characters progress through the
scene so that has a way of slowing
things down a little bit so even though
the script is very tight every scene
ties in directly to to what the main
story is even though like
can seem meandering because of who the
character is everything's there
but the way that the coen shoot it's
almost kind of theatrical where
everything is taking place within a
single frame and characters are moving
within and out without any cuts that can
give the feeling of a slower pace so
it's it's a filmmaking thing more than
it is a screenwriting thing okay
you